I'm the production sound mixer and my
job is to record the dialogue on set I'm
the sound mixer a post production sound
mixer I did the music and the dialogue
sound mixing
I am the supervising sound editor and
sound designer and I was responsible for
taking care of the sound design elements
like vocalizations from the creature
coordinating with our Foley team and
just sort of generally keeping keeping
the team sort of working together and
moving forward along with my co
supervisor Nelson Ferreira who couldn't
be here today and I'm the recording
mixer also for the film I did the all
the sound effects Foley and backgrounds
for the final mix of the film I guess I
start the process by recording the
original dialogues and then these guys
take it from there yeah yeah a lot of
that a lot of the the the product that
Glen Records gets handed over to our
assisting editors and and ultimately
delivered over to Nelson Ferreira and
Angele pretty on the dialog side and
they just go through and clean it up
fine select takes and make sure that
everything sort of comes together
seamlessly so that we have the cleanest
version of the production audio when all
is done as possible right hopefully
hopefully and then for Brad and I we we
kind of work closely to sort of craft
and melt together the the work that I
put into the project and as well as my
team we've got a an amazing team on this
one of sound effects editors really
passionate people who you know they put
their back in every frame that got
delivered and so yeah Brad and I would
would talk in the early stages about how
we're gonna lay that out and organize
things so that it was organ amah for him
to do his work which he will speak to in
a minute coordinate the mix yeah and
then and then basically make sure that
make sure that the the Foley artists
know what's important to the director
make sure that you know just make sure
that all of all hands on deck are aware
of what the
the direction is if there's any sort of
master overall directive that we all
need to follow I was the guy who's just
making sure that people knew what they
what they needed to cover and sort of
splitting up the the work into
manageable pieces and then once that's
all done these guys deliver all the
elements the dialogue music or well know
there's a dialogue the sound effects and
the Foley to the mix stage where Chris
and I will put it all in and also we get
from the composer the finished mix
tracks for and we basically build this
the sonic soundscape for the entire
movie with the director and picture
editor in this point and yeah basically
put it together for what you hear in the
theaters once I've delivered my tracks
I'll just check in as they're as they're
mixing just to see how it's going but
really it's all in there yeah their
hands after that what point do you at
what point does your phone ring and you
know that this is a project for you a
few months ahead of the head of the
production yeah I'll get a call and
check my availability and I'm just
curious who does that call come from
generally the producer or if it's
Guillermo movie is Guillermo right I
think yeah that's that's sort of when
when we came into the picture so Nelson
again and I as well as Doug Wilkinson
our post-production supervisor we kind
of wanted to work together on something
for a while we had a few close calls and
it wasn't it wasn't really lining up for
us and so you know individually we had
all had lunches and sort of decided we
want to we want to work together and
then this came up and it kind of fell
into place at least for me it sort of
fell into place as a result of that I'm
not sure if there was more footwork for
Doug to to make that all happen and come
to life but you know in the end we end
up sort of getting getting our wish and
yeah what what came off of that was we
wound up getting getting scripts sent to
us and I was actually on vacation when
they came through
and and I get to really kind of read the
script on a flight home and was pretty
excited about it cuz I was coming home
to a meeting that we had been invited to
where we would sit down with Sydney
walinski - picture editor as well as
Guillermo you know it's an opportunity
for Guillermo to share with us his
intention for this creature not as a
creature but as a lead man as a romantic
lead and so the sort of the creative the
the early-stage broad-stroke creative
discussions took place in that meeting
where we talked about you know what what
kind of tone does this creature take
does what kind of range will he have and
then a few another like a few other
small details that he just wanted to
make sure that we understood were
important to him mainly atmospheric
things like the sounds of the lab but
yeah then once that was done we kind of
got to go off and start planning and
scribbling notes down and begging
production to lend us vehicles that we
could go and record and do all of this
stuff that would sort of help us get the
ball rolling so that when we actually
started the post schedule we had the
materials needed to get going there's
recording mixers we very undependable
relationships with directors and
producers we'll know earlier but in this
particular job neither of a sudden well
Chris had worked with Guillermo on the
strain before and but I had never worked
with them I'd worked with the
post-production supervisor on a previous
film so I reached out to him to to get
my resume and that's a Guillermo -
because I was really interested in the
product during projects Ari and and I
was brought on board at that point I
mean Chris was just oh you're working on
that oh great Christo venture yeah
what's that they're still not material
I'm not sure did I I'm not sure for me
it was like we're creating you know
Nathan's creating and I'm mixing and
trying to make this this creature that's
a more Mantic lead and make it
believable and you know that doing the
sound creating a whole soundscape for
for the lead in a in a film is
you don't get to do that every day and
yeah that was for me
kind of gonna be an exciting challenge
and and also working with Guillermo it
was a was a big career highlight for me
yeah
man reading that script was was it was
like an out-of-body experience I was
like talking to the my co supervisor
Nelson about it afterwards and you got a
look at this from just a craft
perspective as a dialogue editor he's
gonna be dealing with a character who
doesn't speak as his lead and I'm gonna
be dealing with a creature who speaks
without words and so like just the
creative opportunity that's baked into
that idea alone had us just salivating
over this thing like he got to take
Nelson got to take a role of almost a
sound effects editor in that he was
going to be cutting together they did a
full like a breaths pass he was cutting
together breaths and small like you know
emotive gestures from from Sally Hawkins
you know through the film through the
whole the whole movie just to sort of
give her that presence at urgency where
it was needed you know kind of give her
that you know thoughtful vibe right and
and then for me yeah a creature who
isn't just angry and doesn't want to eat
you you know there was it was amazing we
got to we got to make somebody feel sad
feel happy feel curious you know connect
with with the the female lead the movie
and the audience as well yeah and and
you know that was and that was a big
that was a big motivators how is the
audience gonna react to this guy because
you read that script it's really strange
you know like they just you you you you
picture someone pitching that and and
you gotta ask are you high like this is
a you want you want a merman to be the
romantic lead in this movie but they
pulled it off like they it was amazing
when we actually started seeing it come
together
and so you gotta take part in that was
it was it was yeah like you said a
career highlight kind of a main early
motivation for where we pulled the
sounds from for the creature was
actually doug jones on set they so he's
the he's the actor who played
the role of the creature and and onset
he was making some kind of like sounds
like he was making these sort of
guttural clicky sounds like they almost
felt like glottal clicks that he was
making to communicate with Eliza and
that was just part of the character that
he was playing that paired with just his
presence that sort of Matador stance
that he took those were sort of big
motivators for the kind of expression
that I wanted to bring to him
beyond that it was it was just sort of
exploring exploring what what we what I
could do because the the the base layer
of the creatures voice is my own voice
and so you know I had the microphone in
my studio at home was like a bottomless
pit of material I could just turn it on
and explore and see what I could do and
and you know that all springboarded off
of what what Doug gave us in his
physical performance and what he did we
were able to capture it wasn't a you
know I didn't mic the creature or
anything intentionally it was just it
just happened organically I guess you
could say it the same time as Michael
Shannon's characters is torturing this
creature and and whatnot so the water
from our perspective was it was a kind
of a metaphor for love the creature
can't live without love the creature
can't live without water he can live
outside of water for a while and so you
know it played a big it it played a big
character in the movie there was a whole
conversation between me and and one of
one of the sound effects editors on the
team Tyler with him where the rain storm
at the end had to be a character in
itself we wanted to show up with an
immense amount of detail for that for
that storm and just because like that's
that really embodied the turning of the
tables right this it felt to me like the
creatures world was falling down from
the sky on to this world right and we
wanted to make it feel like that so yeah
Tyler Tyler did a lot of very specific
textured detailed water surface
recordings and
and things like that and he wasn't the
only one everyone kind of pitched in on
that front we all kind of if we heard
something I know that like Kevin Howard
contributed some some water movement in
his bathtub at home I did the same I
have a skylight we had a lot of rain in
Toronto that year so it was always
possible to throw a microphone somewhere
and catch something
get something that would be used in the
movie and most of it did most of it
found its way in you know whether it was
massive curtains of rain sweeping across
the docks at the end of the movie or
even just like little little ear candy
textures like the waters the water drip
was hitting the the foreground side view
mirror when Strickland is staking out
yeah there's a little detail if you're
if you listen to that track and we were
able to play with a lot of a lot in the
room and a lot of movement and like
you'd get and it was yeah there was lots
of nice little detail we were able to
bring into all those moments water gave
us a good opportunity to provide a lot
of depth to the world because it was
such a an omnipresent source of sound
its own character yeah well I think
there was just so much so much detail
that we could work with like in every
every different set had had so much we
could play with and these guys delivered
us such amazing tracks of details of
little things and we could create quite
a nice little little meal I would have
ever seen and yeah like cannibal
elements that we could like in the lab
scene you know the Guillermo shoots a
lot of sweeping camera and and very
fluid motion kind of and we were able to
do a lot of panning and movement and
stuff like that that's it's sort of just
nice and tasteful that you don't really
notice but if you sit there and and
really dissect the track you can hear
here like a lot of that and and I know
the music and and in particular Sally's
apartment where where they she lived
above a theater and you can hear the
score coming through the floor
throughout all the scenes and maybe
Chris can talk about that immorally that
certainly realistic and also use it as
score as well just to heighten certain
respects on the scale
so it's nice to sort of go between those
moments and and and use that score from
the films and the playing in the theater
as as dramatic moments that's on their
own and use them as score instead of
source music at certain points
everything and it was just it's an
interesting interesting concept that
neither of us have ever worked with
before and I think came together
beautifully it was also really fun to
kind of poke fun at the serious world
using sounds like the the fully the
fully team Steve band Pete Prasad and
Gina work they put together this amazing
track specifically for Strickland it was
a note that we got from Guillermo early
on this guy is uptight and he wears
clothes that are too tight his shoes are
tied too tight the leather has to creak
and so there's all these little things
that we could use to kind of poke fun at
how seriously like they take themselves
too seriously in that lab yokas chair
his chair in his office creaking on
scene where he's where he's interviewed
Aaron he's with with Sally and
interrogation and it's like every
movement there's like that key on the
chair he's he's clicking on the candy
and it's just yeah yeah it's just this
constant you know self inflating
government facility that you know
meanwhile you've got these strange
little like the Jetsons curtains oh you
know but yeah it was it was just kind of
fun because that wasn't it to be a very
serious stuffy environment but you know
it's easy to pick on this here because
they take themselves too seriously for
me on production sound it was getting
rid of separating the dialogue from all
the effects because Guillermo loves the
visual of water running and steam and
creaky chairs and eliminating as much of
that so they could put it in later that
was my challenge knowing you guys were
going to put it all back you take it out
we put it back nice separation between
the darl
in the in the facts so we can pull the
dialogue out from the screen but for me
the biggest challenge was probably the
the dance scene and blending Sally's
dialogue in with Renee Fleming's opera
singing in the dance number and making
those you know blend seamlessly from one
character to the other and then back
again
for me the the the clear contender for
biggest challenge will be the creature
just because you know it had to he had
to be so much he had to be a bit of a
defining character in the movie and that
was going to be the focus of the bulk of
my time and part of that challenge was
just you know being able to trust that
and and he made it easy actually but
being able to trust Guillermo de to give
me the space to do it and know when we
were in progress versus when we were
taking what we were listening to
seriously because with that much work to
do and that many layers to work with
you're gonna hear some things that are
in progress that aren't fully fleshed
out and it was kind of it was tricky to
kind of decide okay when do we when do
we devote a lot of energy to this and
when do we not when when is it midstream
and we come back to it but yeah the
creature was definitely the biggest
challenge for me and for me the biggest
challenge I'm with Nathan is is that
creature was you know we created every
aspect of that creature from the ground
up and it had to sound like it was in
that environment with the actors with
the dialogue that had been recorded on
set and it's uh just to make that all
work and come together using you know a
number of tracks of Foley for all the
movements of the skin there was like
slime move slimy sort of sounding
movements for every time he moved as
well as the gills and the eyelids and
blending all that with the with the
hundreds of tracks of vocals Nathan gave
me to deal with and just sort of put
that all together in the environment and
make it work and sound real and sound
like it was just always there and
movie and yeah it was a that was the
biggest challenge and I think my biggest
proudest moment was I think we pulled it
off amazingly and you know you'd never
know that that was enough that was
recorded from the ground up and how
about the Easter Egg here at Gare Moe's
voice in there
yeah yeah using gear mo is one of the
elements Gemma was all the creatures
breathing yeah yeah yeah all those
breaths and things like that game in a
vacuum uh yeah very breathy yeah we're
generous with this time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]